no
aveva curato innaffiato e amato poi
frammentato in passi concretizzabili di
umanizzato spogliato della sua
connotazione poetica per diventare reale
però resta sogno è tutto parte da un
sogno è l'inizio della mia vita io sono
stata il sogno di una mamma e di un papa
che volevano una figlia e dopo mia
sorella che si chiama gioia sono
arrivata io disperazione questo ha letto
mio papà qualche anno dopo quando ha
iniziato a tirare fuori il mio bel
caratterino i loro hanno compreso che da
questo sogno che diciamo che non aveva
proprio i lineamenti di quello che
avrebbero immaginato da lì dovevano
ripartire con una concezione nuova
comprendere che il sogno che ero io
andava curato andava innaffiato ma
soprattutto andava amato e amare è stata
la parola chiave della nostra vita e
loro mi hanno amata esattamente così
come sono e abbiamo capito che la nostra
prospettiva di vita era un po diversa da
quella delle altre famiglie dove in
realtà due mani che agli occhi degli
altri non c'erano si sono trasformati in
due piedi oppure come piace chiamarmi a
me le mani in basso e queste sono le mie
mani che mi permettono di fare tutto
quello che voi fate con le vostre mani
un po che in su
e allora io ho subito compreso che il
sogno era proprio quello che i miei
genitori mi stavano mostrando attraverso
la nostra vita
quindi trovare qualcosa che sia ma per
cui investire tutto se stessi investire
le proprie energie e le proprie passioni
e allora quando ero piccola io ho subito
iniziato a
mi piaceva tanto sporcarmi di colore e
immaginare delle figure in movimento
attraverso i miei i miei quadri e poi il
mio corpo che quando sentiva una melodia
si muoveva danza e piccolina io amavo
dipingere danzare sognando un giorno di
farlo davvero
lo sognavo e soprattutto quando mi
chiedevano che cosa vuoi da fare da
grande e simona
qual è il tuo sogno io dicevo voglio
fare la pittrice e ballerina è un po
come il vostro silenzio di questo
momento era la stessa cosa che succedeva
quando ero piccolino
e oltre al silenzio il sorriso si
smorzava in poverina questa bambina
voglia e vuole fare la pittrice la
ballerina e soprattutto i suoi genitori
non le dicono niente le dicono anche che
può farlo e allora io mi rendevo conto
che però ogni volta che ripeteva questa
cosa la reazione che ricevevo dal
pubblico non mi piaceva e non capivo se
era per i sogni perché fare la pittrice
la ballerina erano due cose un po
strambe anche messe insieme diciamo che
non hanno proprio un grandissimo senso
agli occhi degli altri o perché le
sognavo io perché ri sognava una bambina
che non aveva le braccia e allora per
cercare di capire meglio ho iniziato a
fare dei piccoli test è il mio primo
piccolo test era quello di provare a
cambiare sogni quindi trovare dei sogni
che fossero un po più conformi a a
quello che magari segnavano le altre
bambine quindi alla prima volta che mi
venne chiesto cosa vuoi fare da grande e
io dissi voglio fare la maestra uguale
alla reazione di prima ma come fai a
fare la maestra che devi mettere i piedi
sul sulla cattedra e poi bambini come
fai a stargli dietro e non puoi fare la
maestra
caspita anche la maestra non va bene
proviamo n'è un altro allora mi veniva
in mente la giornalista voglio fare la
giornalista mi piaceva scrivere e mi
dicevano ma poi come fai a fare le foto
fare interviste a viaggiare andare in
giro a incontrare le persone
caspita è anche questo va bene ma la mia
mamma il mio papà non mi dicevano mai
niente ora non mi dicevano di no diceva
o sono matti miei genitori o sono matti
gli altri quindi non capivo non mi
quadravano i conti
allora un giorno tornando con la mamma
in macchina dal dentista vedi si mamma
ma se io facessi la dentista e mia mamma
mi guarda mi di eccessivo forse piedi in
bocca la gente magari
e allora ho capito che non erano i sogni
che non andavano bene non sarebbe andato
bene niente agli occhi degli altri io
non avrei fatto non avrei potuto fare
nulla
e fu la prima volta in cui mi resi
davvero conto che in realtà i veri
limiti sono negli occhi di chi ci guarda
io non per me non erano limiti per me
usare i miei piedi come fossero mani non
è un limite è la mia realtà è il mio
modo di essere ciò che in realtà io
credo sono venuta qui a fare però per
gli altri
era impossibile e continua ad essere
impossibile per alcune persone
e allora ho compreso una cosa molto
importante e fondamentale che mi avevano
proprio insegnato i miei genitori
accogliendomi come un grande dono nella
loro vita amando mie dandomi gli
strumenti per crescere soprattutto gli
strumenti di credere davvero alle mie
capacità
alle mie potenzialità ai miei sogni non
a quello che gli altri avrebbero voluto
non voluto che gli altri ci dicevano non
si può
e così ci siamo presi tutti questi non
si può li abbiamo messi dentro un
sacchettino e riteniamo un po nascosti
lawley nascondiamo completamente perché
ogni tanto ci ricordiamo che si può fare
sempre di più e sempre meglio però allo
stesso tempo non lasciamo che nessuno ci
possa dire che le cose non possono
essere fatte soprattutto se quelle cose
partono dalla parte più profonda di noi
e i sogni sono questo sono ciò che è
dentro di noi e che ci parlano in molti
modi a volte gridando a volte in maniera
più silenziosa a volte anche con un po
di paura ma sono quella spinta che
quando diventa talmente forte diventa
calore diventa forza diventa amore
che è la parola che mi permette ogni
giorno di svegliarmi la mattina di
scegliere di fare quello che faccio di
indossare la cosa più importante che ho
è che è visibile a tutti che è il mio
sorriso il mio biglietto da visita per
dire io ci sono ci sono così sono stata
disegnata e creata in questo modo e in
questo modo io faccio ciò che amo
profondamente e se lo posso fare io
lo possiamo fare tutti
non ci sono scuse non ci sono
non si può ma ci sono solo proviamoci
il passo dopo passo giorno dopo giorno
troviamo il nostro modo che può essere
diverso da quello degli altri ma il
nostro per fare è rendere la nostra vita
un vero capolavoro è però il mio punto
debole
sapete qual è e che dopo che ho parlato
tanto e io parlo tanto dopo che ho
dipinto e anche lì dipingo tanto e anche
danzare bisogna danzare tanto perché se
no non si può diventare una ballerina mi
sento fragile esposta e anche se non
vorrei mai smettere di parlare di
danzare di dipingere non vorrei mai
smettere di stare su un palcoscenico che
è la mia seconda casa
devo farlo altrimenti potrei disperdersi
negli occhi altrui nei vostri occhi
e allora non sarei più io simona e
allora quando arriva quel momento io mi
inchino l'inchino e ringrazio chi mi ha
dedicato tempo e soprattutto chi mi ha
dedicato a cuore
sento i miei capelli che scivolano lungo
la schiena e arrivano a terra
e allora quando vedo i miei piedi inizio
a immaginare un nuovo
giugno
grazie
beatrice mazzola
grazie di cuore
grazie
emozioni ragazzi
anche l'atto grotte grazie